hey friends and welcome back to Deep
dive the weekly podcast where every week
it's my immense privilege to sit down
with academics and authors and creators
and entrepreneurs and other inspiring
people and we find out how they got to
where they are and the strategies and
tools we can learn from them to help us
build a life that we love what you're
about to hear is an interview between me
and Dr Arya now Dr Arya is a clinical
psychologist who specializes in
psychological resilience resilience is
the ability to accept understand process
and grow through emotional pain first of
all we have to accept and acknowledge it
next we have to release some process it
then we have to understand it and then
we can grow through it and the final is
to act in line with our values and our
vision he's worked with Academy Awards
winners high profile creative artists
Global entrepreneurs and some of the
world's most successful CEOs and I've
worked with individuals who've created
multi-billion pound companies and
products who are deeply dissatisfied and
discontent with where they are it may be
bringing in a huge amount of income but
they don't feel fully fulfilled because
they've lost something along the way
he's also the co-author of the
best-selling book a mindful year and he
regularly features in Publications like
the times and the Telegraph and Men's
Health and in the conversation we talk
about firstly our life Quest and how we
can find Our Truth power of
vulnerability and how to build greater
resilience we talk about the importance
of struggle when it comes to growth and
there were so many parts of the
conversation where I literally got
goosebumps from the way that he was
describing the stuff I was like oh my
God this is like he's literally speaking
truth so so that hits my soul so much
that I'm getting Goosebumps there's a
storm coming and it's going to hit the
question is will we be able to find the
cam amidst the storm
at the moment according to the YouTube
analytics 81 of you who are watching
this on YouTube have not yet hit the
Subscribe button and so if you're for
example in the now 81 of people who are
watching this on YouTube but who are not
subscribed to the channel I would love
it if you could do so and would be
awesome to get that number down to 50
and it would be cool to get like 50 50
sub non-sub ratio just just for fun so
Dr Arya thank you so much for joining us
on the podcast oh it's a pleasure I'm
delighted to be here so much to talk
about um around mindfulness around high
performance around Behavior change
around the things that we struggle with
when it comes to behavior and things but
before we go there I wonder if
um for people in in our audience who
might not be familiar with your work or
who you are I wonder if you can just
kind of Blitz through your backstory in
in a few minutes like what's how did it
how do we get here what's the backstory
I was born and bred in Glasgow so my
father is Persian he's from Iran and his
family were from uh diplomatics close to
the Chevron and he studied Manson and
when he was 19 he moved to London and be
began to train in the UK and my mum grew
up in a very tough upbringing in Glasgow
and her family said you know if you
wanted to go into the helping profession
you should be a nurse but my mom always
said no I want to be a doctor and she
was the first person in her family to go
to university and she met my dad at
medical school so fast forward a number
of years I was born my older brother
uh and there was two of us for about 11
years and then we had a younger brother
join of he was the joke of he was a
surprise to my mum but or a surprise to
my dad but not to my mum and we had a
very
a very close family huge amount of love
uh my father put a huge amount of
focus and Credence on Academia and
developing yourself my mum
I would say is almost like an angel
she's got a Heart full of love and
really taught me the values of
compassion and understanding and in
terms of my career scope initially
school and then I went to Edinburgh to
study medicine
and
that was really following the footsteps
of my parents and was my first lesson in
the difference between doing what
Society deems to be
what you should do versus following your
intuitive wisdom and your heart so to
speak
my dad was diagnosed with Non-Hodgkin's
lymphoma type of cancer and was great
for it very progressed and he was given
a propagnosis of about 15 survival
and again that was my first introduction
to mortality or life not going the way
that you'd expect it to
and really dealing with a reality that
you don't want to accept and my
girlfriend went through a traumatic
incident and that's the first time I
think I really felt out of control where
something's happening you have no
ability to change the outcome
and I spiraled into depression uh I
didn't know how to handle my emotions
from a kid growing up was very quiet
and if I felt anything I'd push it down
I would just go into my head create an
internal world
and
and I really struggled it just began to
spiral down and I was at the point of
you know considering suicide I was on
medication
and I had this moment where my brother
out of love felt like let's get away
I'll take you to a beautiful place we'll
just have time together and I remember
her standing on a beach in Mauritius
with him and the Sun was shining and the
the waves were rolling up to my feet
and I looked around and the scenery was
beautiful and
I was miserable
and I didn't want to be here and in that
moment I had this instant that
no matter what is happening around you
there's two Paths of external journey
and there was an internal one there's
inner peace and joy and meaning and
fulfillment and these two are not
necessarily connected and so I really
made a spiritual intention to go on a
journey to find what at that time I
could only describe the inner peace how
can I find that sense of Serenity and
calmness so that no matter what is
happening to me I can still
remain standing
and so
to try and yeah Fast Track that I left
uh University dropped out probably more
act began doing the only thing which I
knew that I loved which was working for
charities
began fundraising trained to be an actor
because I struggled to find my own voice
and I I learned a lot through that
process and then one day I was actually
on a pilgrimage with my father
who couldn't continue their couldn't
really carry out the uh the pilgrimage
on its own so I was pushing him in a
wheelchair and I just had this
whisper that came from my heart which is
go back and study psychology so I
literally changed tact went back I had
six days before ucas closed sent off the
application did a doctorate in UCL in
Clinical Psychology specialized and
overlap between physical health and
mental health
particularly looking at
if you were Delta hand at its very worst
for individuals who were told they had a
life limiting disease or they had X
number of months to live how would you
live out the rest of that time with as
much joy as possible
and then I worked at Great Ormond Street
hospital with individuals who
whose children were given a prognosis of
a terminal illness
and as a parent whenever you're
suffering this
immense emotional pain how do you still
turn up to your child how do you still
be there for them and and squeeze any
joy that is still left in that time that
you have which is so precious
and then I did my clinic my uh Clinical
Research in sustainable weight loss and
then from then it was another uh scenic
route to high performance work but I
think that's probably taken about 14
minutes already wow
that's that's a
it's quite a circuitous kind of path I
think often finds a lot with people on
this on this podcast where kind of
someone gets interviewed because they've
kind of made it in a particular field
and you would think that the path was
like oh I knew what I wanted and I kind
of went for it because like why not
um but actually there's a lot of windy
twists and turns along along the way to
to get somewhere I see Life of a it's a
quest
if the quest to
return to your truth and along the way
as you grow up you pick up certain
beliefs or ideas your mind is
conditioned in a certain way because of
the accidents of birth
because of your personal experiences and
we build up all these layers and coping
mechanisms and this Armory that we put
on to protect ourselves and this Quest
is an unraveling uh a shedding to return
to who you truly are and that's the path
that we're all on
and there's a there's a quote
by A.H Almas which always stands by me
which is
all these conflicts the
difficult situations the
problematic situations are not chance or
haphazard they're actually Europe
they're specifically yours designed
specifically for you by a part of you
that loves you more than anything else
and that part of you loves you
more than anything else have created
roadblocks to lead you back to yourself
and you're not going in the right
direction unless you're feeling prickier
in the fade telling you
look here
and that part of you loves you so much
that it doesn't want you to lose the
chance
it will go to Extreme Measures and it
will make you suffer greatly if you
don't listen what else can it do that is
its purpose
so it's like
the obstacles that you encounter are not
a sign necessarily a sign that you're
going in the wrong direction but that
you're going in the right direction
the obstacles are are fire and in order
to be refined
we need to apply heat
there is no growth without struggle
painful experiences are why we change
and the difficulty of how we grow
without it we'll be staying in the same
place and the one principle of the
universe of evolution
we evolve
the world evolves and it will continue
to evolve and it's evolved for 13.8
billion years and it will continue to
evolve the estimates are for hundreds of
trillions of years so
this
process will continue and we've been
given this gift of a snapshot literally
just a a micro
blink in the history of this universe
and we are part of that Evolution and
that's what I see our our purpose here
is to evolve
one of the things I love about your your
story and and the kind of when you've
been another podcast and things is that
you I think do a really good job of
combining the
the woo side of life with like the
sciency side of life and I think a few
years ago I would have been very
skeptical of all of the spiritual stuff
yeah um but recently I've started
reading you know a bunch of Alan Watts
like trying to understand the whole Zen
thing like coming across um you know the
power of now and that kind of stuff and
then speaking to a bunch of guests on
the podcast sometimes during the
conversation sometimes outside of the
conversation a lot of people discover
their route through Spirit to
spirituality through psychedelics or
something like that to make them realize
oh hang on there's something like bigger
out there
um but then you kind of take that side
of things and combine it with the
clinical psychologist approach
I'm very similar to you I I grew up with
Academia and I grew up with science and
I trained as a scientist practitioner
and I value the mind so much
and my expertise is in Psychology is an
understanding how does the Mind work why
do we do what we do and how can we
develop greater self-awareness to be
able to see that the mind is a tool it's
not who we are it is a an instrument and
we can use that instrument for immense
good or we can use it for atrocities we
can use it to
become closer and bring the best out of
a partner and we can use it in a way
that will end up devastating a
relationship and hurting the partner
we've created
the atomic bomb and we've created
treatments for cancer if it's a tool and
how we use it is integral to the welfare
of ourselves and others
and I would always place so much
importance on on the mind and on science
and I'll be 40 this year in the last
couple of years what I've realized is
that
there is more to what we can see and
there's more to what we can test in our
Laboratory
and and I'm putting more value on what I
feel and the experiences which I'm
having which I cannot explain
because
the truth is we can only see a fragment
of
the light spectrum anyway
and we don't see mobile waves or
infrared waves we don't hear every sound
there is we're actually just having this
Limited
splice of reality
and you can even bring in quantum
physics I used to you know I used to
hear World connected
the Buddhists or the Hindus or the
mystics would talk about Oneness and
experiencing Oneness with all and when
you look at quantum physics
on a subatomic level
99.99
is space
there is actually no Quantum physical
difference between myself and this table
whenever I'm tapping the table it's the
electrons and the electromagnetic field
Hitting off the electrons and
electromagnetic field of the table but I
sense of being solid
so the spiritual I think in the
scientific are often intimately
intertwined and there's a way of holding
both
and when we look at even Clinical
Psychology and we look at cognitive
behavioral Theory or we look at third
wave approaches to Mental Health
where do these come from they actually
grew out of ancient contemplative
Traditions from from cognitive theory
grew out of stoic philosophy
mindfulness-based approaches grew out of
Buddhist and Hindu and yogic and
medicines of practices so if we're going
to ask
ancient question such as
what is the purpose of my life where do
I find meaning in my life how can I live
a good life that is is
rich and full of meaning and joy and
and peace then really a lot of the
ancient thinkers and ancient traditions
hold
Vehicles which we we can begin to use to
get closer to our own truth I love it
okay so many so many kind of
um paths to go down here I wonder if we
can kind of frame this in the
almost with the with the lens of high
performance so so you work with
um kind of executive CEOs Founders like
people running you know multi-million to
multi-billion Dollar companies
and
so what are the problems that people
like that or actually and and I guess
kind of more normal people what are the
problems that people face in their
day-to-day life in the day-to-day work
where you find that your experience kind
of combining spiritual with the
scientific can help
so individuals that I work with are
highly brilliant they have creative
minds they're very powerful minds they
are self-motivated they're interested in
self-growth they often come from a place
of care and compassion
and something will have happened where
they feel stuck in their life right now
and it's not something they're used to
they're struggling with an aspect of
their life
and it could be
that they wake up one day and everything
from an external perspective
loose
impressive
but then they have this question which
is nagging which is is this it is this
what my life is all about
or they focus so much on career and on
supporting people around them that
they've lost that sense of balance
and they've lost that sense of who they
are
the relationships are suffering again
they've put so much Focus that suddenly
they've lost Intimacy in the
relationship but they've lost connection
and again they wake up one day and they
they look at the person next to them and
they know that they love them and they
know that they make a great team and
that
they're amazing parents together but
it's almost like two individuals just
living in the same house they don't have
they don't have that connection which
they could see they had 10 years ago
and that is so tough because it's so
tough whenever you know how you like
life to be but you don't know where to
start
and what they've recognized is
it's their own psychology which is often
the biggest barrier
your own mind can either Propel you with
such force or it can hold you back and
keep you paralyzed and keep you stuck
and where I come in is I happen to have
dedicated 10 15 20 years understanding
the mind because the mind follows
certain principles and certain rules
and the more that you can intimately get
to know your mind the more you can
actually begin to
take action or have clarity
from your mind
so it's not about having peace of mind
it's about having peace from mind and in
those moments of Stillness
life becomes so clear you have Clarity
you see
what has gone wrong and where you should
go next
so when when someone comes to you as a
new client or patient or whatever you
call it like a client
do they know what's up with them and
like what their problem is or like what
sort of questions do you ask them to get
yeah to kind of unravel what's what's
going on and what's what's keeping them
stuck
they often have an a very good idea of
the pain that they're in and what
they're suffering and it could be that
life has dealt them hard hand at this
point in The Game of Life
and even bringing in Buddhist philosophy
one of the first Noble Truth is that
life involves suffering
and
from my perspective the three aspects of
reality we cannot avoid
life involves pain it involves
uncertainty and it involves change
and we all face unexpected
and unwanted event in life
I went through three years ago where the
the woman that I loved to rebuilt a life
up together over 10 years one day told
me that she's been having an affair with
a man from work and is pregnant with his
child
that was for me at the time one of the
worst things I could have
imagined just one of them because it
felt like I had lost this world that I'd
built up I lost my wife and our dog
Alfie and the homie created and her
family who
became like family to me and this and
this imagined life of growing all
together for an old man and woman on the
street and I'd imagine that would be of
together and it just came crashing down
now that just happened to be my story
everyone has gone through deep heartache
and pain
so we lose someone we love or we're a
single women love to be in a
relationship or we struggle to conceive
or we become pregnant when we didn't
expect you or we become unwell or a
loved one does or we just face these
curveballs and challenges that work in
our personal life that we have no
control over and we didn't see coming
and so often people know what the
problem is
but what they can tell is they feel
overwhelmed or they feel isolated or
there is
a lack of security in terms of what is
happening
and
they want to find a way from the
darkness into the light
and that is the path that we go on
there's a storm coming and it's going to
hit the question is will we be able to
find the cam amidst the storm
the path has involved cultivating that
inner
strength and knowing and resilience and
compassion in order to deal with
whatever life throws at us
because success doesn't depend on what
happens to you it's determined by what
we do next
and if we can cultivate that place of
Cam so that no matter what is happening
even if there is a storm raging but
still is part of a hurricane is its
Center and from and that place of
Stillness and calmness and serenity
exists within all of us
deep Stone it's a field of Consciousness
which we can access and from that place
of cameras and serenity
it doesn't mean that life isn't
difficult but with a sense of ease and
we begin to flow with life and then life
begins to change the only constant life
will change the question is are we
fighting against it or are we going to
flow with it
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly heal I have been a pain
customer of huel since 2017 so it's been
about six years now that I've been using
Q fairly regularly I started eating Hill
in my fifth year of medical school and
I've been using heel regularly ever
since because you know I like to be
productive I've you know my calendar is
full with a lot of things and often I
don't have the time or don't make the
time to have a particularly healthy
breakfast or a particularly healthy
lunch my favorite flavor is salted
caramel because for 400 calories you get
40 grams of protein which is absolutely
insane and you also get a decent healthy
mix of carbohydrates and fiber and fat
along with 26 different vitamins and
minerals which are all very good for the
body there's nine different flavors of
this to choose from my favorite is a the
banana version and also the Salted
Caramel version so what I do is I take
my two scoops I put them into my
NutriBullet blender type thing although
you can just use a normal Shaker if you
want I mix it up normally with water but
a little bit of milk to add a bit more
of a milkshake like consistency to it
and then I just sip that while I'm on my
desk doing my work in the morning and it
ensures that I get a very healthy
breakfast in that's nutritionally
complete rather than and some high sugar
cereal which is what I would have
defaulted to instead also heal is
ridiculously reasonably priced like a
meal 400 calories comes out to one pound
68 per meal which is super super cheap
compared to what the alternative would
be if you were ordering takeout for
example anyway if you like the idea of
getting these cheap and healthy and
nutritionally complete meals in your
diet then head over to heel.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt which are
quite nice and also a free kind of
shaker bottle type thing with your first
order so thank you so much Hill for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tool into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you can invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you the app also lets you
Auto invest which is a great thing
because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started with investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali at the
checkout that will give you a totally
free share worth up to 100 pounds it's
available on iPhone and Android and you
can check it out by typing in trading
212 into your respective App Store so
thank you so much trading212 for
sponsoring this episode when you're
I guess ex-wife broke this news to you a
few years ago
it strikes me that like you would have
been more prepared than the normal than
a normal person who's not studied this
stuff to deal with that kind of
turbulence
how
to what extent did your prior kind of
knowledge understanding background in
this kind of stuff
help you to navigate that and like I
guess how how did you navigate it or was
that something that just hit you from
like left a feeling like oh like
things are are not as easy as like
Marcus aurelius's book made it seems
whenever it hit all the principles which
I've worked from
just naturally came into playing it it
worked through me I don't think it's
something which I consciously began to
think okay oh I should bring this in or
I should bring that in it's something
which had already begun to practice as
part of my life just the individual I am
I can only talk about something or teach
or train something that I have lived by
and that I do on a daily basis
everything that I speak to you about
with my clients
I do every day for hours every day I'm
continually wanting to focus on becoming
present this present is the only moment
that exists
and in this this moment right now
everything is actually okay
all is well in this present moment
where does suffering kick in if when our
mind pulls us out of the present moment
and then
replays what has happened or creates a
story or a narrative around what has
happened
oh your wife has had an affair it will
then add on these layers of perception
on top of reality so the reality is
she's had an affair this layer of
perception is
I'll never build to get through this I
can't handle this as too painful
there must be something wrong with me
because this has happened I could have
prevented it
what should I have done earlier or
quicker or thinner
it's this story this narrative which the
mind creates around it which is like
adding gasoline onto a fire and it will
just burn stronger and more brightly
and what I've have come to experience is
that continually coming back to the
present moment
the first part and acknowledging reality
a lot of the time we try and fight
against reality but reality will begin
to sink in
the more that we accept what has
happened externally but also internally
what's coming up within me where and in
the beginning in that instance there was
so much sadness and of course there was
anger which was fused into it
and so it's then acknowledging the
emotion
and allowing it to pass and that's a
process
so I actually have an area framework so
the a is to acknowledge
what is happening around you within you
that are is to begin to release this
feeling
to continually let it flow through you
to recognize that the feeling is within
you now if a feeling is within you it's
then our responsibility to deal with it
it would have been too easy to feed you
know you made me feel this way because
of what have you have done and so I'm
going to blame you
but what happens in that instance is I
give away all my power
responsibility is the ability to respond
the ability to act as the definition of
power
and so responsibility holds great power
if I hold my responsibility I hold my
power now wear the mind off in
fights against that is it conflicts
responsibility with fault
and the mind doesn't want to hold on to
fault because it's too heavy for it
but analogy would be like for your
do you ever go walking or do you ever
yeah high level yeah if you're going for
a look for a stroll a little stroll head
down to Pratt use my prep coffee
subscription to get free coffee you know
that kind of thing yeah yeah and so
imagine you're going on but imagine in
fact you're in the countryside yeah and
the storm will bring back the summer
storm hits now whenever you set off it
was sunny skies
it was a lovely like breeze you know
other than the Sun was shining now a
storm is hitting and it's torrential
rain and high winds the weather change
is not your fault it would be ludicrous
if you think it's your fault but it is
your responsibilities how you're going
to respond are you going to take out
your jacket and put on a waterproof are
you going to find shelter are you going
to
even call for someone to pick you up
our feelings it's not our fault okay
they've they've Arisen the sadness is
natural based on what had happened
but it's my responsibility how do I deal
with and manage those feelings next
so acknowledge release yeah then the
eyes to inquire into what this event is
triggering within you
because
reality
it's okay everything is everything is
just unfolding like we talked about the
universe is just continually unfolding
and it has for 13.8 billion years and it
will continue to do so what the Mind
does is it places a
judgment on this event
this event is good where this event is
bad
this is successor this is failure and if
we feel hurt it will have triggered
something within us
there's something that your mind is
probably personalizing
or imagining will be the outcome
and our task is to figure out what that
is so to give you a little example often
what the mind will do is it will
personalize what the person has done so
in this example
with my wife at the time having an
affair my mind will personalize it and
say there must be something wrong with
me I'm not mad enough or I'm not good
enough or whatever that may be
truly the principle I work with is that
whatever anyone else says or does tells
you nothing about you
it only tells you about what is going on
within them within their thoughts and
their feelings
my wife at the time didn't take those
actions because of how she viewed me
she took it because she was in a place
for hurt and fear and we'd lost intimacy
and connection
now my responsibility did I play into
that context 100 and I'll learn from
that and I did and I looked at the part
that I played that created a situation
out of which she acted but I'm not
taking responsibility for her action
that is more indicative of what she was
going through
so once we begin to once the emotional
paths and we can begin to look at this
we can actually begin to learn and grow
through it the way that I Define
resilience is the ability to accept
understand process and grow through
emotional pain first of all we have to
accept and acknowledge it next we have
to release and process it then we have
to understand it inquire what is my mind
making this about learn from it and then
we can grow through it and the final a
is to act to act in line with our values
and our vision
with a place that we want to go to and
the value that we want to hold close to
us on our path
because I've worked with
so many Business Leaders and and
Visionaries and CEOs who whenever
something
huge or detrimental happens particularly
to their business or in a personal life
they lose sight of their vision
and we all need something
to move towards something that is in a
way aspirational
and how we do it feel crucial
Royal Robin was one of my favorite
quotes is from uh this pioneering rock
climbing and who'd scale Yosemite
because the first one to do it without
anchoring or hammering pins into the
rock surface and creating damage and he
said getting to the top is nothing the
way you do it is everything
and I've worked with individuals who've
created multi-billion pound
companies and products
who are deeply dissatisfied and
discontent with where they are because
they're not proud of what they've
created and maybe bringing in a huge
amount of income
but they don't feel fully
fulfilled because they've lost something
along the way
and so the way we do something staying
close to Who We Are
returning to who we are and moving from
that place of freedom and integrity and
Grace is part of a fulfilling life for
everybody
we we've talked a lot about or you've
you've mentioned quite a bit this thing
around uh this idea of returning to who
you are yeah and um you know we just
talked about values and vision yes
um
how does one begin to figure out what
their Vision or values are
um I guess I've come across exercises
and things that you can do for companies
of like you know every company needs a
mission a vision of value values and all
that jazz
how do you approach that for an
individual
the simplest question would be what
would you love
like Ali what Would You Love
so if you if we looked at
relationships what would you love to
experience
in a relationship
intimacy closeness together all these
somewhat cliche sounding words that are
making me feel a bit embarrassed even as
I say them
um and what is about even talking about
intimacy or closeness that is
embarrassing I think well embarrassing
may be the wrong word I think
it feels
it feels kind of cliche like
what what do I want what what would I
love I would love intimacy and closeness
I feel like and what's wrong with cliche
what's wrong with cliche I feel like I
almost should be able to come up with
something that feels less
cliche more
more true to myself I guess I feel like
I almost should know what I want and be
able to describe that in more words than
just throwing out a word like
togetherness or something like that
so you just started by describing some
of the most powerful meaningful
forces in life
closeness
intimacy connection
I do not know any individual who would
not love to experience closeness and
connection
an intimacy that's beautiful
it's
literally it's like hearing poetry to me
whenever you spoke about that and then
you undermined it
and then you completely undermine what
you love yeah and what is important to
you
and actually holding and putting it out
there
felt too scary it was no just it was
like yeah keep it in here keep it in
here it's safer here yeah and
potentially your mind might have even
built up an identity around
being unique and doing doing things
differently and having a clear specific
idea of what something is for you and
that creates a huge amount of pressure
because you have to have everything
figured out before you even start
try going into relationship with that
it's going to be it's going to create
anxiety or it's going to hold us back
from even taking a step into it because
that's a huge ass I wouldn't even know
where to start with that
but if we go back to your truth what was
important to you with intimafine what
was important was connection
and
and for me then the work would be
continually going going back and knowing
and holding our truth and beginning to
act from that place of Truth expressing
Our Truth
because you can have Intimacy in in
other areas other than just romantic
relationship or connection or openness
and we can look at okay what is it well
if I ask you what is it
that in a way would Foster connection or
intimacy
in a romantic context or in any
relationship yes yeah or you could think
about it I guess
I guess for me it's
where we can
enjoy each other's
company without like we can enjoy the
moments where we're doing something but
also the moments where we're doing
nothing yeah
yeah and there's something about that
that feels
like yeah that would be really nice yeah
um
I always have an image of I love the
idea of going on a long road trip and
we're both listening to the same
audiobook and pausing it at moments
where it's like oh did you did it
like that that just happened and kind of
having that experience shared
um I think moments of sharing experience
and
I think when I was at University I
always just liked studying with people
in the room with me even though we were
all doing different things but there was
a sense of
a sense of closeness togetherness
connection yeah sharing the same Wi-Fi
but doing different types of work that
always felt really fulfilling and
meaningful and if I look back at my
University experience those were amongst
the moments that I looked back on with
the greatest fondness those moments of
all of us just sitting in the same room
or in the same Library doing our work
and I think that is
some of the sense of
connection that I would love to have in
basically all areas of my life yeah
that's beautiful
and what you described to me
Echoes what spiritual teachers and
Mystics have been saying for thousands
of years you describe what it looks like
and what I heard from is you can be with
someone and you can be doing the same
thing or you can be doing nothing but
you're you're there together and all is
well
hmm yeah yeah and in that there is
pure acceptance of the other
you could be doing something together
you could be doing nothing but you were
seeing the person in front of you and
you're fully appreciating who they are
and you're not trying to you didn't
describe trying to control or change the
other person you're seeing them and
opening your heart and experiencing the
beauty of who they are in your presence
even if that's doing nothing
and that is love to see the other
appreciate them and acknowledge
this beautiful person in front of you
and even in your description of being in
a library where where people are
together and they're close to each other
but they're also independent they might
be doing their own work or they might be
doing their they might be doing their
own thing you know they're sharing the
same Wi-Fi connection but they're doing
something with that Wi-Fi connection
with an ancient uh poet Persian poet uh
and he describes that love is not to
becoming one but two people being
together in the same place but drinking
from their own cup
that love is actually like two pillars
of uh building
they're both part of the building but
they're independent
that love is like the Cyprus Tree and
the oak tree that are not too close
together that they're overlapping
they're not too far apart that there's
just so much distance but they're not in
each other's Shadow they're standing
they're close enough together but they
have their own independent
your sense yourself everything you
describe there
some of the most beautiful poetical
mystical Minds have described in
different ways
and that is truth
and so whenever we have a better when we
can explore this and begin to understand
it it becomes so clear about
what potential the next PATH will be
because we're returning to what we would
love most
and that's our task for Ali to keep on
returning to what you would love most
what would you love most and we allow
that to direct the way
is so this might just be my failure of
imagination but
with with the whole values think
um people often say that you want to
find a partner who shares your values
and to that I've always been a bit like
like surely everyone has broadly similar
values you know living in the same
Society if you go to Medical with
someone chances are you value kind of
traditional measures of success chances
are you value honesty and integrity and
you don't want to be with someone who's
a liar and the the those all seem almost
like table Stakes
um rather than something I guess quite
unique
um
what am I kind of missing here do people
have their unique sets of values or yeah
I'd say like you're saying at our at our
core
there will be
values of love compassion understanding
and that is part of the
of human consciousness you know this
wisdom there's creativity there is an
appreciation for the present moment
the difference of
some of us have lost most of us all of
us
have lost
or are not yet back to that place of
Truth
so if love is truth it all comes back to
really love or fear there are two forces
in the world love and fear and we're
either moving from a place of Love or
removing from a place of fear
the quest the journey that we talked
about the beginnings to return to that
place of love because love is true so
we're returning to our place of Truth
when we're acting out of Truth we're
moving from a place of love
the mind
is based in fear
so whenever someone is not acting out
their values it's because they're acting
from a place of fear they're acting from
a place of mind
and we can see where we are
from the way that we live our lives I
would say rather than listen to what
someone says about their values just
watch them and see what they do that
will tell you so much more in terms of
are they living from that place
and so to make it simple I would say I
often go back to trying to determine am
I moving from a place of Love or am I
moving from a place of fear
and the more that we can move from a
place of love the more that we are in
flow with life
life will still be difficult life will
still be challenging but there will be a
sense of ease with what we're
experiencing because we're not fighting
it and we're moving through it with more
wisdom more compassion more creativity
more Innovation more understanding more
forgiveness more lightness
and that's the path
okay it's a lot for a Thursday morning
[Laughter]
okay this is why my brother says like
when you go to dinner party he always
says keep it light and fluffy light and
Airy and I'm like I'll try yeah I mean
I'm there one to one with the person
next to me and we're talking about you
know what is the meaning of life
the nightmare this is great this is
great um
all of this stuff that we've talked
about love is truth Etc what does that
have to do with figuring out what your
own values and vision are
if you go back to what you would love
that will be your vision
what you'd love to create the meaning of
life is to experience life okay
that's it fine the meaning of life is to
experience life
experience what this moment when now
yeah that's the this this is it I'm
experiencing this moment with you that
in itself is everything
so then the question becomes what kind
of experiences do you want to have in
life
well what kind of experience would you
want to have in life what do you want to
experience
that's such a uh it's it's
I'm finding myself at a loss for words
because it's it's almost too big a
question to
and I'm kind of in my mind I'm tempted
to well then let's bring it down so then
in in your career what would you love to
experience another way of thinking of it
what would you love to create and what
will you be experiencing through that
creation what would you love to create
in your career
I have to create my
Minecraft what are you building
I think for me personally it's about
um
teaching I love experiencing the feeling
of
learning something new finding a way to
synthesize it and to teach it to someone
else
um
and
I would love to experience which I kind
of do and I guess why that's why I do
this kind of stuff
the freedom to do so on my own terms not
tied to a rotor coordinator or an NHS
Foundation trust or whatever the yeah
the constraint might be and whenever you
learn something new and you synthesize
that information and you pass it on to
someone else
what do you experience how does it feel
um the first word that came to mind was
a joy but then I thought nah too cliche
and then I thought well wait a minute
yeah totally yeah the Dalai Lama and
Devlin tutu there's just been a
documentary created
on Joy
two of the greatest
spiritual and political
icons over time sitting around to talk
about the one word that you just talked
about
Joy I shouldn't be embarrassed of using
that word
there's no reason to be embarrassed
about anything else like you have so
much wisdom you you see truth and you
talk about it but then you undermine it
and throw it away
don't do that anymore Ellie
don't do that don't undermine your power
same thing
like I would say something yeah I would
say a compliment and then I'd
immediately undermine it by like kind of
turning it into a bit of a joke yeah and
that feeling of like oh I I can't be too
sincere because that's that's weird yeah
yeah what would be the worst thing about
being too sincere what would it what
would it say about you
it would it's
I think it's a vulnerability right yeah
it's like putting putting my heart on
the line and being leaving it open to
being laughed at be like yeah yeah yeah
I get that I totally get in there that's
ultimate vulnerability vulnerability is
the ability to be hurt
so it's understandable that your mind
will not want you to be hurt
if any time you're getting close to
putting something out there
that is going to potentially be laughed
at or ridiculed or sniggered at or
rejected
or undermined or diminished
that's an act of vulnerability and your
mind will protect you from it so what
will it do it'll do it'll do it first
yeah
it'll do it first and it'll keep you
safe
but what do we lose by not sharing our
truth we leave everything we lose
connection we lose intimacy we lose
our power like you have so much power I
can feel it in the room with you you're
you're immensely powerful and you have
such wisdom and you have such a
brilliant mind and so with you and you
can identify things and you can simplify
them and you can put them out there and
you've achieved phenomenal success in
what you're doing even when your mind
has been holding you back through
certain fears
what would Ali be like if
you were moving more and more away from
the place of fear and a place of mind
and allowing you to flow in at full
force now I'm getting excited and I
don't know anything about your life
it's like a river
within all of us is a river
and if a river isn't if we look and the
river isn't flowing
as much
then people think oh I need to try and
increase the force of the river no no
you don't watch your have its own power
all we need to do is look up stream and
see where the Rocks where are the blocks
and take those out we take those out we
disidentify with the mind we dissolve
those parts which are holding back that
River will flow and it will flow with
more power and more Force than we could
ever imagine
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been a
full paying customer of wework for the
last two years now I discovered it
during you know when the pandemic was in
on the verge of being lifted and I'd
spent like the whole year just sort of
sitting in my room making YouTube videos
but then I discovered wework and I was a
member me and Angus my team members we
were members of the wework in Cambridge
and they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone on my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific rework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop up with
me I've got some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being an environment almost
like a library but kind of nicer because
there's like a little bit of soft music
in the background and there's other kind
of startup Bros and creators and stuff
in in there as well and it's just my
absolute favorite co-working space of
all time it's super easy to book a desk
or book a conference room using the app
and it's a great place to meet up with
team members if you're going to
collaborate and you'll live in different
places they've got unlimited tea and
coffee and herbal teas and drinks on tap
and they've also got various kind of
after work events that happen like happy
hours and yoga and a few other exercise
type things and you can also take in
guests so often when guests will come
over to visit I'll say hey let's pop
into wework and we'll just work from
there for the whole day and then we'll
go out for dinner sometime in the
evening anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend wework like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 of your first booking so thank you so
much wework for sponsoring this episode
I um worked with a
clinical psychologist executive coach
slash more like yeah at one point last
year and I kind of joke to him that like
our sessions felt more like therapy than
Executive coaching and he was like oh
man everyone says that don't worry about
it this is kind of feeling this is like
a similar kind of vibe
um but I'm curious so like for me I I
kind of know that the
my I guess personal Vision with my
career is around this teaching idea and
this Freedom idea kind of coming
together
um but I'm not in anyone else's head so
I don't know what like with with your
clients when you ask them that question
like what are what what sort of answers
do you get from different people around
what's their own vision for their career
it'll vary for everyone
and so the
what it looks like
in a way doesn't matter
what matches is what do we think we will
achieve through achieving this
okay what do we think this experience
will bring
and sometimes when we return back to
First principles
actually we see that
the outcome is less important what's
much more important is that can I begin
to live these principles out now you're
doing already what's important to you
when we're talking about what you're
creating is to to learn Finn for five
and then teach
beautiful and you're finding different
ways of doing that you can do that in
different on different scales you could
do it one to one or you could do it
reaching millions of people
and it brings you a sense of joy
that's beautiful we'll then just look at
what are the what are the blocks of
of the mind which you're holding us back
and it was interesting like you're
saying that we'll begin to hear
different feedback from different people
and really it's about identifying our
fears
and it's about
moving from a place of vulnerability
because that's where our power is
vulnerability is the ultimate strength
because it's truth
and you cannot
hide truth the Buddha said it for there
are three things which cannot be long
hidden fun the moon and Truth
and it's powerful the truth connects
with people
whenever I did a
podcast that I talked about the story of
my ex-wife
uh on the diary field with Steve
the the number of people that have been
in touch and openly and courageously
shared
similar experiences similar stories
whether or not they're the one that
experienced it or they were the one
which
carried out the affair but they opened
up and they
they show True vulnerability in in
Sharing what they're going through
because I believe the truth connects
with people
if you share truth it transforms
whenever we're even in an argument with
a partner often we go in with anger
but you'll learn anger about
something which has happened now we get
caught up in the level of the Mind
I'll give you a personal example I'm in
a new relationship now being in the
relationship for about six months
and
there was this one topic which
I could sense just kept on triggering me
and I was triggering anger within me and
I couldn't figure it out
and when I was coming in with anger I
was coming in with judgment and when I
was coming in judgment she was feeling
misunderstood unheard isolated and her
mind was feeling attacked because I was
my mind was attacking hers
so then she would defend and she would
attack and then I would get more angry
and I would have to keep on
taking a step back until I until I was
able to see what this was about because
if we're ever angry or hurt or upset
that something was happening within us
we're not seeing reality clearly there's
something within a mind of adding on to
it and I was taking
I was taking something from the past of
what happened into the present and when
I truly shared how I felt the truth was
the truth was I was scared I was scared
of getting hurt
I was scared of
feeling that pain I felt three years ago
because it was
so excruciating
that my mind will want to protect me
from that
when I shared that we take something
from the unconscious into the conscious
from the darkness into the light it
dissolve suddenly the fear begins to
dissolve itself and the other person can
connect and then she approached with
compassion and understanding and
closeness and we reach a deeper level of
intimacy and connection and openness
but it only came from vulnerability
so for you what would
what could being vulnerable look like
I think in my relationship it could look
like
feeling more free to say what I'm
feeling and yeah
yeah I think that's an area where I
I sometimes struggle to know what I'm
feeling
um and like we kind of alluded to that
earlier on in in the conversation
um I was gonna gonna follow that I feel
like
often like someone will ask me how do
you feel about X and
I would immediately construct a
cognitive representation of yeah that
rather than
and you know like my my sister-in-law
might be
might say something like huh it's
interesting that that sentence started
with I think rather than I feel totally
and I'll be like
God damn it you're right
um yeah I think I really I really
struggle to articulate how I feel about
stuff because I think the mind is always
so
yeah and yeah just on in in overdrive
yeah
um Ali you're not alone
one passion I've seen when you have an
individual like yourself that has such a
brilliant mind that's so
intelligent and sharp and Powerful
it begins to in a way
rule the show because it's a phenomenal
Powerhouse of an engine
and
the Mind operates on a cognitive level
so it will continually be pulling you
into your mind and you'll be
experiencing the world through your mind
and what does that mind do it will
create
Concepts and ideas and constructions and
it will understand where things placing
together
I valued my mind so much that I was
always again living in my mind
and what I wasn't connecting to is how I
felt I had no idea how I felt for years
I had no idea
I wouldn't even know how to answer the
question
and in my 20s what happened with all
this emotion was built up what would
happen truthfully is I'd get drunk and
it would all come out
as rage as anger
and we have these moments where in my
20s during the day I would just been
seem so Serene Serene and Cam and then
with alcohol it was just this anger
would burst through because I didn't
know how to connect to my emotion
I didn't even know where to start I
didn't
know how to live from that space and
that became part of my journey of living
from and connecting to my heart knowing
what is here
and over time we become more achin to it
and we can pick we can pick up even
more granularity with it go if something
feels off or I can feel hurt or I can
feel I can feel tightness or tension and
if you want you can even start with the
body you know you can start to notice
when do I feel tight or tense if
something doesn't feel right it's like
something's a little bit off
just even beginning to start with the
body and then we can move to beginning
to notice oh if there's something in my
body what do I what do I feel
what do I notice a stirring there we can
just begin to change it a little bit
more
and it's with so many individuals I work
with like they're doing phenomenally
well in their career but often what has
happened is just like you described
their biggest challenge
is sharing how they truly feel
and a lot of the time
there's actually a bit of a gender
pattern which I've seen
men really struggle to know
what they feel and how they feel and if
they can identify anything into anger
but but anger is a superficial emotion
it's almost like a secular emotion it'll
be a masking a deeper hurt
and then we'll explore
with courage and with openness and with
vulnerability safely what is underneath
that
they will be hurt there that you mind
trying to protect you from and it's
easier to feel anger anger is very
empowering where I've hurt a very
opening
or with often with females they know how
they feel or they're not sharing it
they're not truly sharing how they feel
to the person they love or sharing truly
what they're experiencing at work
and it's holding them back and
eventually though we reach a point where
we think of our thickness we can't
continue anymore because the pain of not
connecting to our truth and expressing
Our Truth is too much
because we go back to that Quest what
will life do it will bring more and more
situations into your life to get you to
look at this look at this alley look at
this
I don't think it's a coincidence that
your girlfriend said there are times
that you share and then you pull it back
and I've said the same thing today life
is saying to you Ali
look at this I love you Ali and this is
part of your path
take a little lick
and it's beautiful you have people
around you and you have a partner who is
also to bring in another aspect of love
can be a part of your emotional and
spiritual and psychological growth
now you've got two people who feed each
other who love each other who share and
are supporting each other to grow and
you can grow together
that's a blessing
yeah
doesn't mean it's easy though yeah it
doesn't mean it's easy and look I made
the same mistake one of the aspects I've
learned from most through my 10-year
relationship and marriage if I didn't
share how I truly felt
because I was afraid of hurting the
other person
I didn't want to create conflict
I didn't want to create pain for someone
else and I was afraid that if I said how
I truly felt that is what would happen
but instead I moved away from my truth
and everything fell apart
what's the balance there like
you know people some people would say
the key to a relationship is to not
share how you truly feel about
everything like if she asks you if you
if she looks nice in the dress the
answer is always yes kindling there's
that kind of people are clearly being
you know a bit flippant when they say
things like that but I feel like there
is like a truth there underneath that
around
if you were to sample 24 times a day how
do I currently feel about my partner and
about my relationship that feels like an
almost unhealthy level of sampling
um to what extent do you agree or
disagree
anytime we feel
anger frustration
uh resentment disappointment
uh anything that we call a negative
emotion towards something else there's
something wrong with you
oh
okay interesting
the mind will blame the other person
what I'm saying is
there is something within you're wearing
a lens or a filter right now we go
through life with a clear lens and as we
go through life we're driving the car a
little bits of dirt flick up and they
hit onto the windscreen and now we're
looking at the landscape saying gosh
that bit's dark gosh that bit's muddy no
no no there's nothing wrong with outside
it's your lens that's what we need to
clean first
so
it's about recognizing anytime I feel
emotion there's something happening
within me
it's within me it's my responsibility to
look at
where people go wrong if they think that
sharing truth means
do you know what you're really pissing
me off because you keep on doing this
and I feel like you don't care and I
feel and you're not respecting me
and you're not good enough eventually
what we think and you need to change so
we've got a little mini dictator in all
our heads and what it says is reality
isn't right I want to feel safe and
secure
so what I'm going to try and do is I'm
going to try and control reality I'm
going to try and control what's
happening around me
and I'm going to try and control you so
that you don't trigger me
no no no no no no no no
where there's love there's no control
where there's control there's no love
moving deeper we want to see what it
what is being triggered Within Me
what is what is the hurt really about
I'm I'm sharing that I'm realizing that
for instance I
feel unloved
and that is not your fault
that is don't just saying I want to
share something and I'm not saying your
fault this is something I'm I realize I
need to work on but there's a part of me
that feels unlovable
and feels like I don't deserve to be
loved and you know I'm going to work on
figuring out maybe where that came from
and I'd love to work on healing that
and whenever you say or do this you're
not doing anything wrong and I
understand and maybe we'll get to know
what your intention is behind it
but I personalize it or my mind
personalize it and it makes about
something else and you know in those
moments when I feel alone and
and hurt
I'm gonna try and not attack you and I'm
gonna try and share how I feel
because when we share truth of how we
truly feel
when someone opens their heart it opens
the other person's heart
anytime you begin to like open up a
little bit about how you felt Ali I felt
even more connected to you and I was
fascinated and I wanted to know more
about it
and if we weren't making a podcast and I
wasn't also wanting to bring something
for people to listen to
I would just sit down and we would want
to know more for hours
because it's beautiful because truth is
beautiful
even amidst the pain and what we see is
insecurity there's still Beauty
it's like kinsugi that Japanese art form
these Beauty and perfection in the
imperfection
and so part of us creating compassion
for that
so I imagine you have
clients who
for them expressing their inner truth
um could potentially
cause a drop in the value of their
business
um and I sort of just to to use an
example that's that that I see a lot we
have however many students on our kind
of this course that I run to teach
people how to be YouTubers and at the
start of someone's Journey I'm always
like look just share whatever you want
make videos about anything it's it's not
going to get views anyway so don't worry
about it like you know just lower the
bar as much as possible but at some
point
um you get to a an area where it's like
oh damn I've got I've got an audience
now and I've built an audience by making
videos about Finance
um but I really want to make a video
talking about mindfulness or talking
about yoga or talking about the power of
psychedelics or something like that
but my my business my channel is about
finance and so while I might feel pulled
to share my truth around meditation I am
worried that
the finance audience won't care and that
it will cause my channel to be become
less good in the business term fall and
stuff all of that kind of thing and I
imagine if I were working with I don't
know a billion dollar CEOs that that
they have to be very careful about the
truth they put out into the world for
fear that it will reflect badly on their
brand or their business or their team
like if I had a company of 50 people my
truth might be
I actually want to fire all of them and
just go back to just being me making
websites for freelance clients yeah but
sharing that truth would be pretty
disastrous for my company and everyone
would Mutiny and et cetera Etc yeah so I
guess my question is how do you balance
the sharing of your internal truth and
living true to that with
the market yeah they were yes
it's an understandable situation it's
one that I see time and time and time
again in multiple areas and multiple
ways
we can even take one example one step
back in terms of individuals who are
leaving University
and
you can be looking at two options on one
page very well another one doesn't
Jimmy Caro put it in a beautiful way
what's your price
how much would you have to be paid to
give up on what you love
50 Grand a year when you're coming out
100 Grand a year
150 200.
there'll be a point where without
awareness
will pay the price
it's the same question at any level
what's your price
what are you willing to let go of to
follow truth
and some people the price is too high
for them 100 million 200 million 500
million
no no I'll
I'll forgo
truth
for
the external
and that's a choice
and it's not saying that it's a bad
choice there is no good or bad just both
will have consequences
now does it mean
oh suddenly you quit your company
and everything falls apart
no we also live in this world it's about
being
in the world but not of the world so you
may see that actually this is truly
where I want to move into and is there a
more strategic way is there someone that
I could bring in who could begin to take
over the role that I'm doing or do I
want to continue to grow on scale or
would I be happy keeping the company at
this level or is there a way of me doing
both at the one time or is there there
could be
an infinite number of possibilities to
even take a step closer towards you
moving from a place of Truth
I'm not saying throw the baby out the
bathwater I'm not saying suddenly create
radical change
you may and that is may work but what
I'm saying is if we can just take one
step closer to connecting to your tree
things will begin to change in and of
themselves and I feel and look
there's a number of examples that come
to mind and they reach a Crossroads
we're literally
they're out of critical juncture in
their career and let's say the company
okay well the company is worth
200 300 million but if they go down a
certain road we could be worth we could
go public could be four or five billion
the mind
will say well most likely go public with
awareness I've met individuals who have
chosen not to do that
because they've lived it for the last
one years two years three years four
years and it isn't what they expected it
to be and yes you have more wealth than
you have more Financial Security and you
have more and more and more but inside
is less and less and less
and you're feeling more disconnected and
more out of align with who you are and
will reach a point where these
individuals where with awareness to say
no that is not what my life is about my
life is not about keeping the 50 people
in the company happy my life is not
about doing something for someone else
because they say you're good at it
you're good at Ali for do it and do it
again and do it again and don't leave it
don't don't change lane
foreign
is in doing what they love and then
whenever that may change they can they
can they continue to move to what they
love and often they end up being
successful in that area too
okay well I'm doing you know marketing
and that might be worth X but who knows
you can move into meditation and you
could be making
x to the power of four but your mind
won't see it that way it wants to keep
you safe
that's all I'm saying is
the more we have awareness the more we
can sense when we're coming from a place
of fear and when we're coming from a
sense of
freedom and love
then we can use the tool which is the
mind which is brilliant you would have
much better ideas about probably how you
could pivot in that way because you
understand you know the industry or you
understand psychology or you have that
intimate knowledge
you know how things work you'll be
creative you're able to take two
different parts and bring them together
so you will then find a way you then use
your mind to say okay mind this is what
I would love to achieve what I'd love to
create help me find a way your mind will
find it it will work with you okay Ali
this sounds like an adventure let's do
it
so it's like you're
you know that question I'll tell you
around how do you figure out your vision
your values that's based on your own
internal truth
and then the Journey of moving in that
direction well that's that's a path of
the mind can figure out yeah absolutely
absolutely your mind will become your
best friend it will help you along the
way but if continually moving back to
seeing at what point am I now moving
more towards the place of fear because
the more that we create the more we have
to lose yeah
in a way it's easier when you're at the
beginning of your career and you've got
that happy go lucky well what's worse
that could happen
but then we build and we create and then
we have structures which begin to keep
us in place or we have structures in our
relationships which begin to keep things
static but life is not static life
continually flows
life is like the river
whenever we keep trying keep life as it
is it's like taking a bucket going to
the Niagara Falls taking the water and
saying oh I've got the Niagara Falls in
my bucket yeah no no no
you just took away the magic of the
water because you tried to control it
and put it in a box and keep it there
but life flows so if you keep on flowing
with your truth it will keep you and you
will have
you will often end up in a place that
you never even imagined in the first
place but it's more brilliant and more
bright and more fulfilling and more
challenging than ever before but you
love it because it's your choice and you
lived your life on your terms with your
agency and your Independence and that's
something that you even talked about
before you want to be the author of your
own story
there's a I had dinner with a friend
like last week and
um he runs this uh agency managing
creators influencers YouTubers and I
asked him to analyze a few like a few a
few YouTube channels of some other
friends of mine and there was something
he said around this like he wasn't he
was analyzing a friend's Channel and he
was like you know this friend
um he needs to uh be more experimental
with his content and he said at this
stage the guy's probably thinking
you know I've got I've got this type of
video that's doing well that's getting
lots of views but it's not really what I
want to do forever and he's probably
feeling like he's he can't experiment
now because he's got his Lane
and the advice that this guy gave people
who runs this agency he was like I've
seen this time and time and time again
when you're early in your career like as
a YouTuber or whatever
you can take way more risks yeah at the
point where every video is getting 500
000 views it becomes way harder to take
risks and what he said is that which is
mirror is almost exactly what you said
which is what's your price
um
are you willing to pay the price of
quitting your day job so that you've
created a new day job for yourself in
your YouTube channel where you're only
allowed to make content about Finance
even though you fundamentally don't want
to do it and if that's a choice you make
that's fine but recognize that it's a
choice yes and recognize that there's a
price yes and I think that analogy kind
of the way you described it as well
connects to
I just see so many occasions in my life
where
there's been a choice between two things
both of both have different kinds of
consequences one is more
internal truth the other one is more
external validation yes and in some
cases I've gone for the external
validation choice in other cases have
gone for the truth choice and yeah both
of our consequences
and we live in a world of polarity in
the law polarity is that we can only
have North if we have South we can only
have left with right we can only have
joy because we have sadness so we can
only have lightness because we have
Darkness we can only have
external validation because internal
security exists
and on this path
remember we will experience and go
through and see what it's like on one
side to be able to return back
to the last so it's not even about
judging the times that we do make the
choice towards validation or attention
or
money or security or status or power
it's just seeing that that will be a
part of our path
and through that we can gain deeper
insight and see what it brings and what
it does not
and see that we have to experience this
in order to
experience the other side and with
greater awareness we can then move to
what is most true and right for us
and that's the path yeah holding both we
don't if not even rejecting one and
demonizing one and then glorifying
another it's just seeing which one fits
well within me which one is the one I
want to begin to move towards which one
yeah move me in the direction that truly
on an intuitive level is right for me
yeah
yeah I find that these days I try and
like whenever I'm on a flight and that
and I don't have Wi-Fi I sit down with
like a journal or an iPad and a journal
and just like try and figure out you
know I sometimes I'll just like pose a
question at the top of the page
um what do I want from my business what
do I want from my health what I want for
my relationships I just kind of write it
out and there was one of these
journaling sessions a couple a few
months ago that led to me realizing that
or what I want from the business is not
to
continue to run
this YouTuber course even though it
makes tons of money actually what I
want is the freedom to explore topics
other than this because I've been
talking about this for three years
interesting and now
we didn't just decide to pull the plug
immediately but we decided you know what
let's make the next cohort the last one
let's turn it into a you know the the
mind and the team found a strategic way
of getting to that truth yes and I was a
bit worried that the team would be like
no that's a bad idea but actually the
team will like great it's really useful
for us to know what you actually want so
we can actually move towards that yeah
and they were like you know we wish you
would tell us more what you actually
want I was like that's surprising
yeah yeah beautiful and Powerful when
you're describing that I had shivers
down my spine and for me that's one of
the signs when I hear truth I feel that
I will be monster it truly connects Ali
that's massive
you had this YouTube course which was
bringing in X which was a structure that
had been created and
was probably
offering and does offer an amazing
product and service
and stepping away from that is not easy
like even to think about the courage
that that takes to even contemplate it
to even allow it to grow as an idea to
even then explore and move in that
direction because you essentially then
connected to what would I love
this life is short
I've lost people close to me that makes
you realize how short life is
if we're going to
give up who we are in our truth and
moving from that place of love
to me that is something which is the
greatest strategy
but to take moments like that
ah like literally it opens my heart and
it connects with me and I'm like that's
beautiful alley that's beautiful
not because of the outcome but because
of you are you're following you you're
doing you you're following the truth no
matter where it takes you
you're following that truth and the and
life reality will take care of the rest
you follow the truth and the rest will
fall into place that's our only task you
follow the truth and the rest will fall
into place yeah
even as even even as I was describing
this YouTuber example my mind was
thinking oh this is a bad example it's
too trivial this guy's talking about
kind of losing people and like wife
cheating on him and I'm just
talking about this shitty YouTube
example like why would anyone care and
then you said that you felt the truth
and I felt like validating I was like oh
maybe I should have shared that because
that was my truth
but the mind is still kind of thinking
that yes yeah this no remember the mind
will do that that's the nature of the
mind you can't change the nature of a
lion the nature of the mind if it will
be fear-based and it will doubt
what you are thinking about and it will
judge it yeah I wouldn't expect any
otherwise
that's what my mind would do but I've
created so much distance and separation
from my mind and I've ignored it for so
long it stops just stop talking
just going quiet how do you create that
distance
by continually recognizing when it is
speaking recognizing that fear yeah and
then going down into that place of Truth
yeah and and still taking action that's
what you did there right your mind said
oh terrible example but you still did it
Ali and that's the point you still did
it you still took that action and it
connected with me
that's beautiful that's powerful that
begins to
show your mind that it's not in control
that actually you have a deeper wisdom
and for whatever reason that
that example came to you and you shared
it I'm
inspired by that
I'm now going to go back and think what
are the ways in which I'm getting tied
into something and should be listening
more to that truth like Ali did
beautiful you just changed my life
literally I'm gonna go back and think on
that because there will be a way that I
am and I already have an idea of what it
might be
what's the idea
the idea is that what I'm the way that
right now I'm in my comfort zone
in that
I
work one to one and I love it and I work
with people who write respect and admire
and it's it's such a privilege to be a
part of that journey and there's a part
of me that's saying
share more in a way where you're in
serving by having conversations like
this I've not done a podcast in
two years for me this was one step to
I should say I've done a podcast of this
of this uh of this type before
because it's a part of my mind that says
don't don't area stay small
don't come in here and tell Ali who's
got
you know a huge following who's
respected and admired in this area don't
begin to ask him questions it's his
show and what you're gonna come
and ask him questions about his life my
mind will
will will do the same things
for the things that it's most afraid
about
so whenever I say yes it goes quiet but
then right now I can sense what or that
is at least what my mind would have said
I can tell already what my mind would
have said it would say all these things
it'll say no error you're not
who are you who are you to talk about
truth
that's so interesting yeah because for
me like what my mind was saying for this
podcast was like oh damn this guy's
really cool he's an expert like he's got
he's got like the spiritual thing the
scientific thing what the hell do I know
about any of this stuff am I kind of
gonna be able to follow the thread of
the conversation in a way that makes
sense for the listeners and in a way
that he feels like he's been respected
and that I want him to go away thinking
that this was a good interview and that
like I knew my and I asked good
questions and it's just a constant like
because we both have human minds and
we're both connected in our Humanity by
by the nature of the mind it's the exact
same Ali we're like it's just a mirror
in front and most people you meet the
exact same they're just a mirror in
front and the path isn't remember
getting rid of the mind it's moving to a
place where we then just follow truth
I've only been able to say what I said
today because
I'm just following my intuition
and whether it was good or bad or there
are points that were interesting or
points that were boring or the points
where the audience stays or they don't
it doesn't matter
because it's about me moving from a
place of Truth and if someone benefits
from it that's beautiful and if they
don't that's okay too and if they like
me for it that's okay and if you hate me
for it that's okay too
because that isn't real
the only
thing which is real is truth
so we're all on a journey you're on a
journey Ali I'm on a journey and there
will be parts will be holding us back
and the journey never ends
as soon as we think we've achieved it
that's when we're in trouble and that's
where we're going to get hit the hardest
now continual growth I have so much to
work on so much to grow through so much
to move from and at the same time I am
exactly where I'm supposed to be
exact same with you
and where you will go
is just the beauty of of Life the
meaning of life is experience life it's
like we're on a roller coaster
it's been unfolding for 13.8 billion
years that will continue for trillions
of years we're just getting to see what
the next part of the roller coaster is
where it will take us
a man is a gift
how did how did you get so good at this
you're like your your Vibe is uh like
for one of a better word very Zen and
wise and
when you said you were 40 I was kind of
surprised because the way you're talking
is kind of what I would more expect from
someone like a sad Guru or you know uh
spiritual teacher who's like in their
70s or something like that
um when were you like this when you're
like 20 like how did how did this kind
of that was a nightmare yeah
in order to find ourselves they have to
lose theirselves and I and I lost myself
and I've lost myself many times in
multiple ways and
and for whatever reason
life is just continually
this will sound ah I was nearly going to
do what you were you were going to do I
was going to say this is gonna sound
cliched my mind was just about to yeah
undermine what I'm gonna say because
it judges what I'm about to say in terms
of how I'll be perceived life loves all
of us and life love itself we are
if life is
the dancer we are the dance
and the sense that I've always
felt is that God or the universe or life
loves me and even in the times when I've
suffered the most
there's still love there and there's
love that will support me through that
and again it goes back to that sense of
not God why is this happening but God
where are you taking me it's it's a part
of a bigger picture and I just can't see
that picture right now now the mind
again like we said it tries to take a
snap judgment and determine it as good
or bad
with a then story of the farmer I don't
know if you're aware of it but
essentially a farmer his horse runs away
and all the all the neighboring Village
uh people come and say off such bad luck
and it says good luck bad luck who knows
and they seem a bit perturbed by it
they're confused by it or bemused by it
and then the horse comes back but it
brings ten other wild horses with it oh
the villagers say that's amazing what
good luck good luck bad luck who knows
then one day his son is riding trying to
train one of the wild horses kicks off
he falls and breaks his leg the
villagers come oh what terrible luck
good luck bad luck he knows
the uh
sun is now lying in bed he's injured the
Army comes through and they're taking
young men to for conscription to the
army they see that he's injured so they
leave him villagers come oh my goodness
what amazing luck we know the answer
good luck bad luck who knows
the mind will assign each
moment of good or bad success or failure
but we're not seeing the bigger picture
it would be like taking a book
opening up to a page reading one line
and saying oh my goodness this is a
horrific book this is a terrible big
this is awful this is the worst book
I've ever read we've only read a line
we take another big can we open up and
wow this is a beautiful big I know
exactly how it's going to end
no no no no no
no that's just a line we take this
moment in our lives and we say this is
awful this is terrible I can't get
through this no no no no no no no part
of it is beginning to take a step back
and see there is so much I do not know
and that's Faith that's trust that's
trust that this is unfolding
and not only that all will be well but
all is well that moment of what happened
yes at the time I would say it was awful
terrible painful it's the best thing
that ever happened to me
I wouldn't change it I wouldn't undo it
I had to go through that to grow and
evolve as a person because I'd lost
myself I wasn't connected to my truth
and now I will not give that up
not for anything
and I've met
um in a beautiful relationship where I'm
experienced the depth of sharing
vulnerability I've never had before I
never would have had that because I was
stuck in my structure and life came and
said you know what all right you're not
gonna move
I wasn't going to
I made a violin of two commences I was
staying there it was the only way that
life was able to shift me onto a
different trajectory
and it happened and it happened through
me
and it's led to
this path which is still continuing
still growing and I don't know what will
happen next
but as long as I follow the truth
reality will take care of the rest
um we've talked a lot about
um kind of feelings emotions and stuff
and the impression I get from from the
stuff you've said is that you know the
feelings are almost
the truth that we need to connect with
um but then in for example
stoicism and in some other schools of
thought there's the idea that well
feelings are a bit of a myth there are
only really four feelings like
um
discussed pleasure
um salience and like inattention or
something like that and everything else
is uh the mind or culture or Society
putting labels and constructs on top of
fundamentally just these four things
what's your take on how
true or quote valid or quote real
feelings and emotions are
um in this kind of in the in this Arena
I put more and more value on my
experience
are emotions real
I experience emotions and so that is a
part of my internal reality
what we do with what we're experiencing
is when the Mind becomes involved it
will then
categorize and create
delineations and structures in order to
try and understand reality
and that is an act of the Mind
with emotions we even know that
labeling an emotion for instance
decreases the intensity of the emotion
so on a neural level
if you're experiencing anger and you're
able to identify I am experiencing anger
it actually
strengthens the circuitry in the
prefrontal cortex and will dampen down
the older more Primal parts of the brain
which are responsible for emotion like
they make Glenn and so even labeling an
emotion can decrease its intensity the
words that we have for an emotion impact
our experience of it there are tribes
around the world that have
labels or emotions that we don't even
know
and the
scientific understanding is that they
will experience emotions that we don't
because we don't even have a word for it
and so
we could get lost in this but
essentially what I bring it back to is
what is most effective
even if we tie into high performance
high performance is taking effective
actions effective times
when we often make poor decisions is
when we're acting from a place of
emotion
when fear goes up intellect goes down
so
if we're looking at wanting to make a
strategic move within our business or we
want to
create something within a relationship
part of it is knowing and sensing and
feeling the emotion that's there because
I know that if an emotional is there now
is not the time to make a decision
in the beginning you've got one problem
and I could be the work issue at hand
as soon as the emotion gets involved
you've got a second problem
which is all the feelings around it the
anger the frustration the disappointment
the feeling of disrespect
it's only once I've created space for
the feeling and allow that to dissolve
will I then look at what that initial
problem in the world is
and I suppose as part of your Aria
framework sort of acknowledge release
and then you can inquire as to what's
the trigger here
precisely the first step is the
acceptance part it's allowing the
emotion to be there to recognize Victor
acknowledge and to release it until
outflow through this only then do we
have access to the greatest part of the
brain which is the
the part responsible for the the
Judgment of a situation holding multiple
options in mind assessing and weighing
up the balance impulse control that
executive control of what to do next
that comes into play and we can use the
mind of the tool to reflect and the
Stokes would do that with a great time
during the day where they would reflect
on on their life or on what makes a
meaningful day or on
what they're taking for granted or on
where their worker growth is
but the first part has to be the
acceptance allowance before the change
can take place
we can only change what we accept
let's say you're working with with one
of your clients or even for yourself
and you're having
I guess you're having an issue in the
business or in your personal life where
you're feeling kind of these emotions
coming up and
taking you away from from the present
moment what
what are some examples of what this kind
of acknowledge release Inquirer thing
looks like
can you think of
a time where you felt maybe in the last
week or two where you felt it difficult
a difficult or challenging emotion a
negative emotion where you felt anger or
frustration or hurt
okay so in my relationship for example
often there'll be times where or
sometimes there'll be times where she's
busy with something or other at work and
hasn't replied to a message for a while
mm-hmm
and
my mind will start thinking oh have I
done something wrong
um
and usually like I feel like I've been
drinking this doseism Kool-Aid for like
a decade and so I can
then almost override that with another
part of the mind with the voices of like
you know
Ryan holiday and all of the original
stoics in my mind being like Oh you know
control the things under your control
like her response is not in my
controller all of all of that kind of
stuff with them come and make me well
sort of somewhat override that but I
think the core feeling at it is still oh
have I done something wrong here
so it's a very simple example but for
instance uh
uh and in this case the gender was the
wife asking the husband are you able to
come home tonight at 5 45
and he's CEO of a company
and he was explaining this to me he got
he's like I just felt so frustrated and
angry because she knows I can't come
home at 5 45 on a Tuesday because I've
got that board meeting and I'm saying
look why are you putting this pressure
on me in order for me to be home
whenever you know I can you need to be
more understanding and he got frustrated
angry at her and then she got defensive
and got upset with him
and it led into a spiral whenever we
began to break it down
what he was doing was he was acting from
the emotion
so the three things or three traps that
people fall into one is they try and
avoid the emotion the emotional pain we
try and avoid it reject it negate it
push it down
and just not feel it
but what happens in that instance is
that it's like
putting a suitcase into a basement it's
not disappeared but we put in another
suitcase in another suitcase and
eventually our whole basement is filled
and it's going to start coming out we're
not going to put anything else in and a
little bit like pressure building up in
a volcano eventually it then just erupts
so they're all these instances
beforehand where he have
felt frustrated and just said okay do
you know what
I'm just going to to stay calm don't
react and he just moves on but he hasn't
connected to the emotion and so it's
still there and it builds up and over
time frustration and anger hardens and
turns into resentment
so now we're seeing through a different
lens and filter so one is we're trying
to avoid the pain the second mistake is
that we fuse with the pain we create a
story or a narrative around it ah my
wife doesn't understand she doesn't care
she's not shown me the respect that I
should have and it's created a narrative
around
respect or not being loved the third is
react out of the painting and in that
instance the person then got angrier
snapped in at later conflict and then
that conflict leads to a a rupture in
the connection in the relationship
part of the path in a very simple
example of disease to acknowledge what
am I experiencing okay there is Anger of
frustration remember anger is the
surface level
what is beneath then once we begin to
you know acknowledge and release it and
then he and I together can explore it
beneath the
anger was actually guilt
the truth is he feels bad
why does he feel bad he feels bad
because there's a part of him that feels
like I should be home at 5 45.
and there's a part of him that feels
like he's not being a good enough father
or not being good enough
husband
now the mind will try and protect from
that because that's a hard truth to hold
so what will it do it will then
turn it around and attack the other
person
finger making me feel like a bad
husband are you making me feel like I'm
not doing enough no no no no no we can
only
experience what we judge ourselves if we
feel hurt by something it's because part
of a part of us believes that it's true
so repeat that if we ever feel hurt or
upset or resentful or angry about
something part of us is holding that
same judgment towards ourselves
if I said Ali
you're a burrito
how are you feeling just kind of amused
yeah yeah
it's almost quite comical yeah what you
will not say is what are you calling me
a burrito I'm not a burrito no no how
could you think I'm a burrito I've never
been a burrito I don't have I don't have
guac I don't have beans like this is
this is outrageous
how could you how could you even think
that
no no you're not gonna say that because
there's no part of you that believes
that you're a burrito yeah no part of
you you know that's not true yeah
as soon as a partner says something
which even Intimates that I feel like
you're not giving enough that will only
hurt if part of us feels that we're not
giving enough to you
yeah it's like with
like online comments the only ones that
sting are the ones that have a grain or
more than a grain of Truth to them yes
like if someone says Ali your typing
speed is really slow and be like
your content was better when you were
actually a doctor and you were living a
real life instead of just being a
full-time content creator I'd be like oh
damn he went there yeah yes completely
yeah completely
now whenever it hurts
again remember our mind will try and
protect us from feeling that hurt yeah
so then
defend and justify and excuse and try
and convince the other person but truly
itself why that is not the case because
it doesn't want to hold that truth even
if it's a one percent morsel of belief
in that
but the level of evolution is in direct
proportion to the level of Truth we can
hold without running away
if you can hold that truth and see it
we can bring it from the darkness into
the light from unconsciousness into
Consciousness and it begins to change on
its own
Carl Jung said until we bring the
unconscious into the conscious it will
direct our life and we will call it fate
it's what we're unaware of or do not
accept or judge or push into the shadow
side which ends up ruling of and
dictating how we behave and act and it
won't be in line with truth because
we're rejecting truth we're not holding
truth
so it all comes back together you take
it back to the example when he could
truly see you know I have guilt that I'm
not being the husband and the father
that I want to be
and he shares that with his wife and
says you know
when you asked me to come home at 5 45
I'm so sorry that I got angry and I
attacked you because it
isn't to do with you
is to do with me because what it brought
up with me is I feel bad and I feel like
I should be home and
there's part of me that's judging me for
not being a good enough partner
and I'm sorry if that is the case and
something I'm working on
that's a conversation that's
vulnerability that's truth that leads to
change that leads to two hearts opening
and coming together and saying I see you
and even that part that you shared
that's okay
you have a wound
and that's okay because I love you it
goes back to you the way that you
described love what we pulled from
because I see you
and I see all the parts that you like in
the parts you don't like and it's okay
what's the balance between
I guess being yourself
versus choosing yourself
in the sense of for me my my default
self you know we talked about how the
self is you know
um a result of accidents of stuff my
default behavior is often to prioritize
work at the expense of everything else I
am the happiest person in the world if
I've spent five hours in the evening on
my laptop from 6 pm to 11 pm
um but that's not really the person I
want to be I want to be a person who has
more balance who takes care of their
health and their relationships and who
views time spent with loved ones loved
ones not as a
you know I wanna I'd rather be on my
laptop but more like I'm genuinely happy
to be here in the present moment even so
that's that's kind of who I want to be
but it's not who I am if that if that
makes sense so how do we
how do I know which one is more quote
authentic because I find that my mum
often says sometimes that oh you know
Ali you know you're you're trying to
change for other people and stuff this
was when I at University I made the
active decision that I wanted to become
more confident and charismatic and be
more of more outgoing whereas in school
I was a massive nerd and played World of
Warcraft all evening yeah and so to my
mum that was the the real me and she
would say that you're fine as you are
you don't need to change I'd be like no
but I want to change like I wanna I
wanna level up that's just better I
think to be more confident I'm going uh
yeah what do you reckon
there is the
conditioned self
and there is true self
there is
the mind and identity
and there is
spirit
what we've come to identify of who we
are is actually the construction of the
Mind
the mind is created an identity we enter
this world and then the mind is trying
to understand
who am I
what does that mean who are you what is
this world how do they all fit together
and it creates an identity and it builds
one
and it builds certain understandings of
the world and what people do and
intentions
and it's mapping out this internal world
and that is down to the accidents of
birth that is down to like you're saying
you know your family your cultural
experiences the place and time in this
universe that we have this opportunity
the mind will always do that then there
is true self which is just consciousness
and the nature of Consciousness is love
is truth
the mind says I need to get everything
in place and then I'll feel at peace the
soul says be at peace and everything
else falls into place
we've been living from our minds for the
majority of Our Lives though
we've been living from that place and
we've built up Armory and we've built up
coping mechanisms to navigate
the path is beginning to
take off some of that Armory
to see that actually when I connect to
truth and love I will
then see what it looks like you don't
need to figure that out
if you can just go down into that place
of Truth and Love
you will see
what it will look like
because one thing we do know is that the
mind is a terrible predictor of what
will make us happy
it's got all these ideas
my life has to look like this it should
look like this and then I'll be happy
we've got no idea
we've got no idea we don't know what's
going to happen in one minute of time
so to take away all their configuration
for the mind trying to
even choose or a map or or build or be a
lot of
self-improvement is talking about
improving who you are or optimizing who
you are which is based on the premise
that you are not enough
you're not good enough you're not whole
enough you're not
you're not enough so you've got to do
more of a change to be better and get
being caught in the same trap
move away from mine down into
Consciousness into that field of
consciousness tap into that place of
love and into intuition and move from
that place of Truth and then we'll see
what it looks like
so what does that look like in my
confidence I want to be confident
because I feel like I'm not yet
confident and I would like to be more
that way yes yeah
this idea that you're not confident is
an idea
take away the illusion
and then we'll find truth
so it's
the more that we begin to
drop out of the Mind the more that we
create separation from the mind we'll
just begin to notice oh gosh my mind is
just saying that I'm not confident gosh
my mind has created an identity of of
who I am it's got its idea of who Ali is
and we can be curious about that and see
it from a distance as if you're
observing another person so what is
identity that my mind is created about
Ali
who does my mind say that Ali is what
does my mind say Ali can do in kanji
gosh what does my mind judge that would
be inappropriate for Ali to do we just
begin to see we begin to see how the
mind created all these preconceived
ideas and Notions oh gosh it says that
he's not confident
the more that we create separation from
it and we see it and distance from it we
will then just be moving from truth and
the truth is
you are neither confident nor not
confident
you just are
you are neither
brilliant nor not brilliant you just are
the mystics would just say I am
that's all we can say I am and there is
no there's no label that we can attach
to something which can capture reality
okay
There's No Label which can accurately
capture
ultimate power and love there's no name
for it it's just pure power you are pure
power you're pure even that's just a
name or an idea but you're just pure
power and
and and energy
and we'll see where that energy can go
but when we move from that place even
the idea of confident and confident
doesn't make sense anymore
it's like what
you know color is the number seven
that doesn't make sense that's not who I
am that's not that's not what I am
it's just then more ramblings of the
Mind
you move from that place of power
and you will all that will happen is it
will be unfoldings and you'll just begin
to
so if we if if we if we turn to
confidence then into something more
concrete like
ability to play finger Style on the
guitar
ability to play finger finger Style on
the guitar you know that kind of that
kind of music
such an ability yeah so you can
accurately assess yeah what if my level
of ability in terms of playing the
guitar
yep and I can choose to actively improve
that ability or increase that ability if
I want to yes similarly if I like
confident is
a bit Dodge but if I were to think
instead of
being confident which is like a almost
like a character trait that is has a
value judgment on it because more
confident is generally better uh yes
Society judges but instead of it
thinking at thinking a specific skill of
public speaking while doing
presentations specific ability to go to
a pretty girl and talk to her specific
ability to
whatever completely those are then areas
in which I can decide okay I actually
want to work on my presentation skills
therefore I'm going to watch some
YouTube videos and do some practice yes
but I'm not
using that as a way of thinking
therefore I am currently unconfident
because anyway that also becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy
completely so we can build up individual
skills
and say the the key part though is just
seeing when the mind is making judgments
and being able to see that as just the
nature of your mind which is a tool
because whenever you live from a place
of
no mind or just live from a place of
presence
you're not even thinking about
confidence or not confident so if I
think about me right now
how am I coming across as confident or
not confident I'd have to make a
judgment I don't know
like potentially some people might say
yes or no it doesn't matter I just need
to be me
if I think about you right now are you
coming across as confident or not
confident again I think people have
different I would say you're coming
across as yeah confident with
with the way that you're holding
yourself other people will say oh well I
think maybe he's holding back it doesn't
really matter if it's just Ally you just
be Ali
full stone
and we can only be who we truly are
whenever we can truly connect to truth
when we when we return that Quest
returning to who we are the truth of Who
We Are
and acting from a place of love maybe
I'm being pedantic here but yeah let's
say someone has an important
presentation coming up at work yes and
they're like cool I wanna I feel like
I'm not particularly confident on stage
I'm not particularly confident with
doing this presentation
surely what you're not what you're
saying is not
oh don't worry about practice just focus
on being who you are and connecting to
your internal truth and
then or or is that what you're saying or
am I just misunderstanding
there'll be different roads okay and
there's different routes yeah I'm
talking about if if we're to get
specific yeah but I'm I'm talking about
this lifelong spiritual journey okay
and
that's something which we're continually
working on
are there shortcuts to putting on a good
presentation absolutely
you could have a teacher and get them to
show you the hand yeah movements to make
the eye contact the intonation
the choice of lexicon yeah yes and that
could be a fascinating skill to develop
and so absolutely go on that road and go
on that path will that though
take away the real problem which is the
Mind believing that we're not good
enough okay yeah will that really
address the mind's doubt that I don't
deserve to shine my light yeah that
actually who I am isn't as good as other
people and actually I should say small
and if I show up vulnerability I'm gonna
get hurt
don't put yourself out there don't go
and speak to the person don't take that
career move don't take that risk to move
away from what's bringing money to move
towards to what I love
yeah nice I like that it's like the I
always chuckle when uh by YouTubers
students are like uh you know I'm just
waiting for for a better camera to
arrive and then yeah and then and then
I'll and then my videos will be good
enough for me to make my first one yes
I'm always like ah yes let's let's dig
down into that yes because the camera is
not the thing holding you back
completely yeah there's individuals who
I've met who've been close to me
incredibly close to my family who
are
so powerful
that when you're with them you're just
drawn in
it's like uh a magnet and who
can I've met people who can go on stage
and speak with such Clarity and with
such connection that you're just
lost in their words
and these individuals I'm not known to
go and do a 12-week course on public
speaking
or to researched
what to do they may have done that along
as well as but what I
know to be true it's because they're
moving
from their place of Truth
nice I think that's a great place to end
this all right thank you so much thank
you I have so many other things to ask
you about which will um we'll be able to
do a part two talking about mindfulness
and Zen and kind of the things you
learned being an actor and I have all
this stuff around here around pain
uncertainty change but we'll save all
that for part two um where can people
learn more about you or find more of
your stuff
you can check me out on Instagram
uh or on my website cool and we'll put
links to all of those in the show notes
or in the video description thank you so
much Ali thank you for sharing your
truth with me it's been a privilege all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye